life threatening cold is sweeping across
the northern half of the country
windchill advisories are in effect for
much of New England and New York and
northern Pennsylvania temperatures are
plunging to the single digits in places
like Pittsburgh at least one person is
dead from exposure in Chicago
International Falls Minnesota hit a
record 37 below yesterday this dramatic
satellite image of the Great Lakes shows
the clouds behind the massive snowfall
they've also seen DeMarco Morgan is in
Erie Pennsylvania where even more snow
is piling up on the five feet that has
fallen since Christmas Eve DeMarco we
can barely see you there good morning
you know what I can barely see myself I
feel like I am buried in this snow but
we're actually walking through a car lot
for the first time which is directed
located directly across the street from
the hospital here the local hospital and
it appears that this area hasn't been
touched since a Sunday storm first made
impact listen to this guys were already
averaging in hundred inches of snow just
for the city every year that's the
average we are now at 102 inches of snow
for the month of December alone crazy
for thousands of people pummeled with
snow and Erie Pennsylvania there's no
rest for the weary mostly work 36 hours
straight
blough drivers like Dave Wanda are
struggling to make roads passable this
is probably the tenth time we bought
this place and they're just keep plowing
it's not
but where the plows are failing children
and neighbors have stepped in when this
car got stuck in a snowbank strangers
pulled over to help get it back on the
road they look what they need somehow so
why not sisters Azeri militia and
Madison McCall are trying to make the
best of it
we haven't had a winter like this since
we were little kids and it just feels
good to be playing out here again in New
York a state of emergency is in effect
for us we go County after they were
blasted with more than five feet of snow
I've lived here my whole life
we've really got fire fighters in Lorain
used bulldozers and shovels to rescue a
woman who was trapped in her home by a
six-foot snow wall much of the United
States is also getting blasted with
bone-chilling cold a bridge became
partially stuck in Green Bay Wisconsin
because of the frigid temperatures and
this is the Grand Haven River in
Michigan in Minnesota temperatures
dropped it's a 40 below zero in some
parts and Minnehaha Falls turned into an
ice cave it feels like your skin is
gonna be on fire it hurts after you're
out there for a little while all right
now
the good thing is that the local airport
is back open so that's a good sign that
we are making progress and we're headed
in the right direction but guess what we
could get up to seven more inches of
snow before it's all said and done and
these lights are so bright guys I've
been looking in just about every
direction but the camera I think I'm
looking directly at the right spot now B
got it we'll send things back to you you
are looking at the right spot and please
maybe it's the mother and me DeMarco get
inside it if the bones are really cold
out there thank you we'll do